[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans le département
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
édition quelle école du futur pour faire
réussir nos jeunes c'est la question
posée lors d'un colloque à l'assemblée
nationale organisé par génération
entreprises entrepreneurs associés un
groupe qui rassemble 150 parlementaires
une réunion publique des républicains
yvelinois sur les enjeux européens
un événement organisé jeudi soir à bois
d'arcy avec notamment la présence de
sophie primas sénatrice des yvelines
elle est notre invité enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur le
lancement du plan climat air énergie
territorial de saint quentin en yvelines
et sur la mobilisation concernant la
piscine de maurepas légis les jeunes de
coignières ont été évacués ce jeudi soir
par des crs
une évacuation décidée par le préfet qui
s'est déroulée dans le calme
la mobilisation sous forme de barrages
filtrants devant le dépôt pétrolier de
la commune a commencé dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi dernier une
manifestation qui s'organisait autour
d'une sorte d'un village de gide est
jeune elle avait reçu le soutien de la
mairie réfléchir sur l'école du futur
c'était le thème du colloque organisé
hier à paris par le groupe génération
entreprises entrepreneurs associés
composé de 150 parlementaires ce groupe
de réflexion a été cofondée par le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
jean michel fourgous une matinée durant
laquelle plusieurs intervenants ont
partagé leurs expériences
or élire 11 étaient sur place
l'importance du numérique dans l'école
ou encore le rapprochement entre l'école
et l'entreprise
ces pistes ont été évoquées à l'occasion
du 2e colloque de l'année pour le groupe
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés c'est un thème d'actualité
parce que il parle à la fois
numérique il parle du respect il parle
de l'exigence du devoir et puis
également ne jamais oublier la
récompense parmi les intervenants
frédéric castaignède dans son
documentaire demain l'école le
réalisateur fait un tour d'horizon
mondial des meilleures pratiques
pédagogiques
le modèle asiatique avec singapour ou
encore le modèle nordique avec la
finlande
ces caméras ont également suivi des
classes élan courtoise utilisant le
numérique et l'encours est
particulièrement avancé sur l'innovation
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que c'est pas
seulement de l'innovation technologique
mais aussi pédagogique on voit dans les
classes par exemple cette organisation
en îlots qui travaillent sur
l'engagement actif des enfants le
travail en coopération et moi ce que
j'ai pu constater à l'issue de ce tour
de monde des meilleures pratiques
pédagogiques c'est que le là on a parlé
par exemple du numérique à l'école
le succès du numérique à l'école c'est
quand il est intégré dans la pédagogie
du professeur composé de 150
parlementaires entrepreneurs ce groupe
et force de proposition il a également
pour vocation de combattre les préjugés
dont peuvent être victimes les
entreprises ont mis en relation avec
d'autres think tank qui n'ont pas les
mêmes moyens d'accès au parlement et il
ya également des chefs d'entreprise et
des gens l'associent civils et ont
réfléchi sur les grands problèmes
bien sûr pour à des solutions qu'on peut
veut faire voter ici pour débloquer la
société en plus des colloques génération
entreprises entrepreneurs associés
organise à chaque mois des petits
déjeuners avec un chef d'entreprise
première réunion publique des
républicains yvelinois depuis les
élections internes en octobre dernier
qui ont porté pierre bédier à la tête de
la fédération et un invité de marque le
député européen républicain geoffroy
didier pressentie pour être la tête de
liste pour les élections européennes
il est revenu sur les enjeux liés à ce
scrutin et sur l'actualité politique en
france cette réunion l'occasion pour
nous de nous entretenir avec sophie
primas la sénatrice les républicains des
yvelines les images sont signés mélanie
poquet sophie primas bonsoir non ça
alors vous venez de tenir une réunion
publique concernant 1
enjeu de l'élection européenne avec en
invité le député européen
les républicains geoffroy didier alors
en quoi ce scrutin qui aura lieu le 26
mai 2019 et la thématique de l'europe et
est cruciale pour le parti des
républicains
c'est crucial pour la france d'abord
dans un premier temps puisque geoffroy
eu l'occasion de le dire ce soir
l'europe ce n'est pas une anecdote
l'europe ceni dans notre identité notre
culture mais c'est aussi notre intérêt
au niveau national que d'être au sein
d'une organisation beaucoup plus large
plus européenne qui soit une force pour
faire face à des blocs mondiaux qui sont
extrêmement puissants
ce sont en particulier les états unis la
chine et je rajouterais d'ailleurs la
russie nous devons avoir une
organisation qui soit capable de nous
porte et nous les français à l'intérieur
une force plus importante que celle qui
est hexagonal aux jambes alors des
enjeux forts pour la france mais pour
rappel les élections européennes de 2014
non l'abstention a dépassé les 50 3%
dans les yvelines comment on fait pour
justement mobiliser présenter ces grands
enjeux pour la france et pour mobiliser
les iguanes
je crois que c'est justement le point de
départ aujourd'hui c'est de mobiliser ce
soir me troupe eux les trouvent les
républicains dans les yvelines leur
expliquer les enjeux répondre à leur
question répondent à leurs
interrogations leurs objections
et puis derrière est en capacité de nous
déployer sur le département pour
expliquer à quel point cette élection
est importante et peut-être que cette
année dans un contexte où il y a des
ordre en france aujourd'hui expliqué de
nouveau ce que l'europe peut nous
apporter est un élément qui me
semble-t-il devrait concentrer
l'attention de nos concitoyens on vient
d'assister à la première réunion
publique depuis les élections internes
qui ont porté pierre bédier à la tête de
la fédération des yvelines comment se
porte le parti aujourd'hui dans le
département on veut écouter se porte
comme au niveau national c'est à dire
que nous sortons meurthe et pas d'une
élection départementale mais d'une
élection présidentielle l'année dernière
qui nous a beaucoup affaibli il est vrai
beaucoup questionné une partie d'entre
nous sont partis parti se questionne
parties sont restées nous sommes en
reconstruction donc nous sommes un
malade qui va mieux
qui sort de la période difficile et qui
a envie de reprendre des forces pour
nous sommes dans une période de
reconstruction
sophie primas reste avec nous on passe
tout de suite au résumé de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
ce mercredi 12 décembre les agriculteurs
évinois se sont rassemblés devant la
préfecture à versailles une mobilisation
contre l'augmentation des taxes
une délégation a été reçue par le préfet
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
les tracteurs ont investi versailles ce
mercredi matin une cinquantaine
d'agriculteurs venus de houdan menthe et
rambouillet venus protester contre
l'augmentation programmée des taxes sur
les produits phytosanitaires en france
des pesticides visant à protéger les
plantes des parasites qu'il faut
absolument que l'agriculture française
et les mêmes règles cox et autres
concurrents européens
on a le droit de mettre les mêmes
produits phytosanitaires pour protéger
nos cultures pour avoir les poneys les
mêmes normes et pas de règlementation
française qui viennent serez empilées on
est en train de courir un 100 m avec un
boulet au pied par rapport aux autres
pays producteurs européens
une délégation d'agriculteurs a été
reçue pendant près d'une demi-heure par
le préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
l'entretien était jugé satisfaisant par
les manifestants je pense que il a une
bonne une bonne approche
je sais pas s'il a beaucoup de pouvoir
et il va pouvoir nous aider dans nos
revendications mais une au muy
montraient une certaine solidarité avec
ce qu'on pouvait avancer une nouvelle
action devrait être mené en début de
semaine prochaine dans les yvelines le
mode opératoire n'a pas encore été
dévoilé alors sophie primas on le voit
dans ce sujet des agriculteurs
protestent contre les différences de
politiques de normes qu'il ya entre les
pays européens
est-ce que l'harmonisation des normes
agricoles à l'échelle européenne est une
solution allait évidemment très réclamé
par les agriculteurs français
l'agriculture français c'est un des
piliers de la fondation delà de l'europe
de la pac
aujourd'hui l'agriculture française est
vraiment leader avec l'allemagne avec la
pologne de l'ensemble de l'europe mais
en france comme nous voulons toujours à
tes meilleurs élèves ce qui montre la
voie ce qui montre le chemin
eh bien nous demandons nous avons des
exigences de plus en plus importante que
nous imposons aux agriculteurs français
alors que d'autres syndicats
agriculteurs à l'intérieur même de
l'europe n'ont pas ces difficultés en
tout cas n'ont pas ces contraintes
alors les français des adducteurs
français veulent bien progresser veulent
bien changer de modèle mais ils veulent
le faire en même temps que les autres
agriculteurs européens
pour être dans des situations de
compétitivité équivalente
donc il faut les mêmes normes pour tous
les pays des 28 bien sûr il faut des
normes une fiscalité qui soit la même
des normes qu'ils soient les mêmes des
conditions de qualité
deux cultures qu'ils soient les mêmes et
il faut harmoniser ces conditions sinon
nous mettons des boulets aux clés alors
je le rappelle vous êtes sénatrice des
yvelines sénatrice l est républicain
ce mardi 11 décembre au sénat vous avez
adopté l'ensemble du projet de loi de
finances pour 2010 9 un texte qui sera
modifiée puisque la veille le président
de la république emmanuel macron à
apporter une réponse à la colère des
gilet jaune sur le pouvoir d'achat avec
plusieurs annonces alors on va lui
rappeler une augmentation de 100 euros
du smic notamment à travers la hausse de
la prime d'activité la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires l'annulation
de la hausse de la csg en 2019 pour les
retraites inférieures à 2000 euros
en complément il appelle les employeurs
verser une prime de fin d'année aux
salariés est ce que c'est une prime
défiscaliser effectivement est ce que ce
sont de bonnes solutions
alors je ne sais pas c'est de bonne
solution mais le président de la
république voulait répondre à une colère
qui s'exprimait et qui s'expriment
encore d'ailleurs dans la rue et dans
toute la france d'ailleurs ce qui est
très impressionnant c'est que cette
révolte d'abord elle touche des gens qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de
manifester les gens qui travaillent en
général qui disent leur exaspération de
ne pas pouvoir vivre suffisamment bien
vivre tout simplement du fruit de leur
travail donc c'est un petit peu hâtive
et il a voulu faire des mesures qui sont
forts que nous réclamions ce n'est pas
des républicains qui vont aller contre
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est un dispositif a
jusque là sans sarkozy avait mis en
place sous sous sous son quinquennat
bien évidemment que manuel macron avait
conseillé d'annuler au président
hollande celui ci l'avait annulé pendant
le quinquennat précédent
on revient à une mesure qui est vraiment
excellente pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français je ne peux que m'en satisfaire
après sur les autres mesures je suis
aujourd'hui un peu dans la tente des
explications parce que vous l'avez dit
c'est pas une prime du smic c'est une
prime de la place et une augmentation de
la prime d'activité pour la prime
d'activité aujourd'hui elle est versée
sous condition donc est ce que ces
conditions seront là aussi pour cette
augmentation de 100 euros
c'est des réponses que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui la même chose pour la cg et
l'arrêt de l'augmentation de la csg sur
les retraites
je ne sais pas exactement quel est le
seuil est ce que c'est un seuil de 2
euros par personne par foyer nous
n'avons pas encore ses responsables
ça sera quelque chose qui sera discuté
chuis bo thedan dans l'est la fin des
discussions sur le projet doit-il l
arrivée à falloir aller très très vite
parce que nous avons déjà fait beaucoup
d'acrobaties au sénat pour voter le
projet de loi de finances on nous
annonce des projets de lois raids
fictifs
rectificatif pardon avant la fin de
l'année pour que ce dispositif puisse
être en place en janvier la cession
s'arrête le 22
il va falloir que ça se discute mais
alors très vite alors on sait que chez
les républicains ce à quoi vous faites
très attention c'est le déficit public
là on voit que ces mesures finalement
vont le creuset le pourcentage du
difficile public par rapport au pib
prévue pour 2019 c'était 2,8 là c'est
remonté à 3 5%
avec ces mesures comment on gère cet
équilibre entre réduire le déficit
public et en même temps accordé du
pouvoir d'achat aux français
l'élection présidentielle portait ce
grand défi pour la france qui est de
réduire son déficit public pourtant d'y
réduire son déficit public c'est pas
juste des mots réduire son déficit
public ça veut dire moins emprunté ça
veut dire arrêtez de faire augmenter la
dette de la france
la dette de la france et une fois son
pib donc ça veut dire que toute la
richesse qu'on produit pour être très
simple ll suffit à peine à rembourser
notre dette
alors on entend des fois des gens qui
nous disent que c'est pas grave on n'a
qu'à pas la rembourser oui donc à pas le
rembourser le jour où on commence à ne
pas rembourser notre dette
on ne peut plus emprunter est clairement
lendemain matin on peut plus payer les
fonctionnaires c'est ça que ça veut dire
c'est exactement ça accélère donc il
faut être très attentif effectivement
difficile de la france c'est un paradoxe
très difficile
le président gbagbo le savait mais ne
l'a pas fait ça commence dès le premier
jour de sa première année du quinquennat
par une réforme structurelle des
fonctionnement de l'état et par des
économies sur le fonctionnement de
l'état c'est ce qu'il n'a pas fait c'est
la marche qu'il a loupé aux premières
années de son quinquennat et je pense
que ça lui sera fatale jusqu'à la fin de
son règne par rapport aux annonces que
emmanuel macron a fait en début de
semaine du côté des gilet jaune
elles n'ont pas convaincu c'est le cas
notamment à coignières depuis samedi
dernier défi des jeunes ont organisé à
un barrage filtrant devant le dépôt de
carburant de la commune nous sommes
allés sur place
regardez un village de gillet jeunes à
l'entrée de la zone industrielle démarré
à coignières des citoyens avec des
situations sociales différentes tous
mobilisés contre la politique du
gouvernement
nous on commence à prendre racine il ya
une chose qui a apporté ce mouvement et
et indirectement le président c'est une
solidarité
il a réussi à voile a rassemblé quand
même pas mal de demandes et on commence
à se créer une petite famille de gilet
jaune et de ceux qui soutiennent à
travers un barrage filtrant les gie les
jeunes s'organisent pour faire vivre
leur mobilisation ce matin des élus de
coignières sont venus leur rendre visite
après l'installation d'une benne à
ordures par les services municipaux pour
voir quelles sont les quels sont les
besoins fait faire en sorte avant tout
que ça se passe bien aussi bien pour eux
que pour les automobilistes qui passent
s'il ya une volonté de donner la parole
aux français aux citoyens par
l'intermédiaire des mairies on le fera
enfin c'était ça me paraît une évidence
augmentation de 100 euros du smic prime
d'activité comprise défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou suppression de
la hausse de la csg pour les retraites
inférieures à 2000 euros
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron est jugée insuffisante
beaucoup de personnes ici que je veux
que j'ai rencontrés m'ont bien fait
comprendre que voilà c'est ça suffit pas
ça suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir d'achat voilà c'est juste vivre
j'ai entendu c'est un premier pas qui
est intéressant maintenant il ya
tellement tellement tellement tellement
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés qu'au final en fait c'est du
vent je le prends comme ça sert que
quand on quand on est sur une
intervention médicale et qu' il ya une
hémorragie on met pas un pansement
on sort les gros moyens et on sauve la
personne cj les jeunes ont prévenu ils
sont prêts à passer les fêtes ici en
famille à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle des marais de coignières on
constate parmi les gilet jaune il ya
différentes catégories sociales des
personnes qui viennent de partout alors
souvent c'est la zone périurbaine il ya
même des anciens chefs d'entreprise en
tant que sénatrice et ancienne maire
d'aubergenville comment vous ressentez
ce mouvement qu'est ce que c'est
c'est très difficile de dire ce que
c'est ce que c'est c'est un mouvement de
désespérance par rapport à une situation
je vous disais tout à l'heure
le gens qui travaillent donc qui sont
pas des gens qu'on pourrait dire qu'ils
n'ont pas envie de travailler par
exemple sont des gens qui travaillent et
qui n'arrivent pas à boucler leurs fins
de mois
parce que sont assommés de charges alors
ça concerne tout le monde ça concerne
celui qui touche le smic et qui n'arrive
pas à finir sa fin de mois ça concerne
celui à qui on a baissé les apl ça
concerne le chef d'entreprise ça
concerne l'artisan qui prend sa voiture
et qui dépense du fioul
voilà ça concerne toutes les catégories
de français et du coup ça devient un
mouvement aussi qui est difficile à
appréhender politiquement parce que ces
personnes ont toutes des revendications
très différentes certaines veulent qu'on
augmente les minimums sociaux
d'autres veulent qu'on augmente le smic
une troisième catégorie veulent qu'on
baisse la taxation sur le pétrole parce
que eux ils ont besoin d'avoir de
l'énergie moins cher d'autres veulent
qu'on baisse les charges sur leurs
salariés parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'embaucher qui voudrait embaucher plus
c'est un mouvement multiforme
protéiforme et ça sera très difficile de
répondre effectivement à tout le monde
on n'aime pas merci sophie primas nous
avoir accordé cet entretien sénatrice
les républicains des yvelines
[Musique]
l'actualité en ile-de-france s'est
notamment l'impact économique du
mouvement des gilet jaune depuis le
début des mobilisations le 17 novembre
dernier
les week-ends se suivent et sont de
moins en moins lucratifs pour les
commerçants un reportage de nos
confrères de via grand paris depuis le
début du mouvement des gilet jaune
les week-ends se suivent et sont de
moins en moins lucratifs pour les
commerçants sur les dégâts dégradation
pillages depuis deux semaines plus de
500 commerces et entreprises de services
ont été impactés
rien que dans les magasins de jouets le
montant des dégâts est estimé à 40
millions d'euros en région parisienne
vous avez par ailleurs un cerf ou
d'activité dans l'industrie je parle
plus du commerce et de l'industrie elle
même qui ne peuvent plus travailler
parce qu'ils sont plus approvisionnés
sur le chiffre d'affaires alors que la
période des fêtes est un moment crucial
pour certains secteurs les entreprises
constatent une baisse de fréquentation
dans les centres commerciaux les pertes
sont estimées à -30% par rapport à la
même période l'année dernière
les répercussions sur l'emploi
pourraient s'avérer dramatiques pour les
commerces le mois de décembre est un
mois de double voire un mois triple donc
ça peut représenter 15 20 % ou davantage
selon certaines catégories du chiffre
d'affaires annuel
ça veut dire que si ces commerces ne
peuvent pas fonctionner normalement sur
le mois de décembre
s'ils peuvent pas rattrapé et je crains
qu'ils ne le puissent pas sur les deux
week-end qui vient c'est à dire que ces
commerces seront difficulté 6 en
difficulté ça peut se traduire par des
dépôts de bilan avec les conséquences
qui s'y attache en termes d'emploi avant
samedi dernier les détériorations avait
coûté plus de 300 millions d'euros en
ile de france
les commerçants espèrent une accalmie ce
week-end pour tenter de limiter la casse
sur leur chiffre d'affaires
c'est une première en france les
salariés du plateau de satory vont
pouvoir se déplacer en navette autonome
doté de perception est tendue et
développé par vd comme elle était
inaugurée ce lundi un reportage de marie
lehn iapichino elle s'appelle framboise
litchi et l avance tout seul
l'institut vd com a développé ses
navettes autonome pour étoffer l'offre
de transport et permettre aux
travailleurs du plateau de satory
d'effectuer le kilomètre manque
entre le dernier arrêt de bus et le
plateau on va vraiment aller très
rapidement sur un usage quotidien de
cette mobilité comme un service de
transport aujourd'hui tout à fait
comparable qu'on vous prenez le bus
quand vous prenez le métro
ce sera la même qualité de service la
même régularité qui sera offerte en pour
ses débuts sa vitesse est limitée à 15
km heure elle est reliée à 16 satellite
via son antenne gps et comprend huit
capteurs appelés lidar pour détecter le
moindre danger de leader sur le toit qui
permettent de détecter les bâtiments on
va avoir un lidar 3d ici un de chaque
côté bien entendu voilà qui permettent
de docteur de voir ce qui se passe sur
les côtés et enfin on va avoir des l'ida
en bas 4 donc et qui vont permettre
notamment de déclencher la chaîne de
sécurité c'est à dire que s'il ya une
personne qui arrive aux navettes
s'arrêtent les navettes autonome ne sont
pas totalement livrée à elle-même elle
communique avec les opérateurs du local
de supervision du mobile à ce service
gratuit est une première en france
si c'est dans le département que
l'innovation ce fait les entreprises les
recherches les laboratoires vienne
s'implante et créer les emplois de
demain
et créer l'aménagement du territoire de
demain et les facilités de déplacement
de demain encore en phase
d'expérimentation ce sont les salariés
devaient d comme qui en bénéficieront
dans un premier temps l'objectif final
étant une couverture plus large du
territoire adopté en conseil
communautaire le 20 septembre dernier le
plan climat air énergie territorial de
saint quentin en yvelines a été lancée
ce mardi 11 décembre à l'observatoire
versailles saint quentin
un lancement qui passe notamment par la
création d'une plateforme en ligne
baptisé eskimos poursuivre la mise en
oeuvre du plan regard des eskimos le nom
de la plateforme en ligne du plan climat
air énergie territorial de saint quentin
en yvelines un outil virtuel destiné à
tous les acteurs du territoire pour
permettre l'accompagnement de la mise en
oeuvre du programme
les gens vont pouvoir suivre de manière
la plus précise possible les évolutions
de consommation
ils vont pouvoir suivre aussi la mise en
application du plan climat air énergie
est également ils vont pouvoir proposer
des nouvelles actions
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
va contribuer à cette plateforme dans le
traitement des données notamment de la
consommation énergétique
c'est beaucoup plus facile de demander à
un certain un certain nombre de
personnes 2
de suivre leur consommation de dévaluer
leur consommation au quotidien à travers
un cadre un cadre d'évaluation kung fu
reniera avec une mini formation que nous
même d'aller chercher la donne est donc
ça responsabilise les gens par rapport à
leur consommation et puis ça permet pour
nous de recueillir de la donnée fiable
au quotidien faire émerger une filière
transition énergétique sur le territoire
ou encore valoriser les commerces en
circuit court
plusieurs actions du plan climat air
énergie territorial lancé ce mardi 11
décembre et voté le 20 septembre dernier
d'adapter le territoire aux changements
climatiques en essayant de à la fois
réduire les consommations d'énergie et
d'utiliser au maximum des énergies
renouvelables pour nous rendre le plus
indépendant possible par rapport aux
énergies fossiles et au nucléaire
on a des gros progrès à faire par
rapport à l'isolation thermique et là il
va falloir à travailler sur des
rénovations énergétiques de l'ensemble
des bâtiments depuis juin 2016 la
plateforme repères habitat permet aux
saint quentinois d'engager les démarches
pour une rénovation énergétique un
projet de centre aquatique intercommunal
qui fait débat mardi soir la ville de
mort pas signer le recours à la gestion
déléguée du projet lors de son conseil
municipal un événement que ne pouvait
pas manquer le collectif piscine pour
tous remontés contre les conditions du
projet les explications de marie lehn
iapichino les images sont signés grégory
canal et depuis la décision de sa
fermeture en avril 2015 la piscine de
maurepas pose bien des problèmes à la
municipalité le projet de reconstruction
d'un centre aquatique intercommunal
entre mort pas et ils encourent à
plusieurs points de conflit le collectif
piscine pour tous s'est constitué en mai
dernier
ses membres étaient présents mardi soir
pour manifester avant le conseil
municipal et tenter de s'y exprimer la
concertation qui a été menée pendant
l'été est largement insuffisante la
concertation mené par les maires est
largement insuffisante elle est
lacunaire
elle est imprécise et elle laisse en
suspens de très nombreuses questions
pour répondre aux missions de service
public des arguments incompris par le
maire de la ville qui a consulté les
habitants il ya quelques mois et obtenu
plus de 3000 réponse est fait avec mon
collègue des locaux et de coignières à
l'époque une grande concertation sur
plus de quatre mois entre juin et
septembre grand public avec un
questionnaire sur internet papier dans
les trois villes
on a fait des groupes de travail avec
l'ensemble des associations
les collèges les représentants des
collèges et des lycées
on a repris tous ses besoins principal
sujet d'inquiétude pour le collectif
partagé avec l'opposition la délégation
de service à une entreprise privée
le maire de maurepas tient à rappeler
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une privatisation
on vous déléguez affaires publiques dans
le privé il y a toujours un contrôle de
la puissance publique qui ait lieu tous
les ans au travers d'un rapport du
délégataire qui est votée en conseil
municipal et ensuite vous avez les
agents de la collectivité qui suivent de
près l'exécution du contrat fait une
obligation dans le cadre des marchés
publics le recours à la gestion déléguée
signé l'appel d'offres sera lancé le 17
décembre pour un lancement des travaux
fin 2019
le collectif se dit pourtant déterminé à
poursuivre ses actions et appelle les
citoyens à les rejoindre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et retour de
l'information lundi à 18 heures avec le
7-8 journal d'ici là à passer un
excellent week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour